he's pitched twice in the big leagues
this year with the angels and both times
he's throwing the ball well for sam
hagerty one for four yesterday
this is interesting here
upton can't get it
haggerty into second with a double
one ball one strike
and that is out to right fields move it
back on it joe adele onto the track
he'll make the catch in front of the
wall tagging heading the third is
hagerty that's good base winning by
hagerty kyle seeker the batter zieger
flares went out toward left center field
tailing away from trout has good speed
on it tracking it down makes the catch
basically in left field for the third
out center and left-hander marco
gonzalez a record of three and two and a
three point
six two era
so one on four the angels that'll bring
up center fielder mike trout
swing and a miss struck him out mike
trout goes down swinging big strikeout
for marco gonzalez garleos the d.h today
marmos six for 16 on the road trip looks
like a jam shot that's exactly what it
was and it works
second hit for the mariners out of the
reach of renee fo
here's second baseman donovan walton
just called up from the mariners
alternate training site
there goes marmalajo swallows we're
going to miss a throw down to second
base a good one that is a strike amount
throw him out
double play that ends the inning justin
upton leads off the angel's second
inning
this one's out towards center field hit
pretty well kyle lewis moving back to
the wall that is gone big fly for justin
upton gives the angels a one-nothing
lead j-up going yard caught that one out
in front center field fourth home run of
the season third versus left-handed
pitching for justin upton going 405 feet
for one-nothing angels rather first
pitch
jake fraley
and phil there you go got extra bases
he's been looking for a moment
see if he's going for three he will
and he's going to get there
so jake fraley his third hit of the
season a lead off triple here's joseph
odom he swings and pulls this down to
left field line base hit fraley waltzes
home from third joseph odom has tied
this game at one
in the third inning ultimate first base
a run in and crawford behind the one two
swinging it's roped into right field a
fair ball into the corner adele having
to chase after it odom is moving to
second now making the turn to third
he'll stop there crawford rips a double
into right field two out two on kyle
seeger the batter two two a little
hooked shot toward the right side ring
hifo shallow right field retires seeger
and maria gets into little trouble i'm a
berea will depart here after 71 pitches
in a 1-1 game matt andres is up on the
mound halos have kept lewis off the
bases so far
chopper towards short handleton simmons
will go the short way they force out
crawford and we'll head to the bottom of
the fifth bring up jared walsh
popped up odom seeger taking a look
seekers gotta play well done
i like when you see opposing teams
teasing each other and breaking chops
like that getting away here in the sixth
is marmot one for one with a walk
swinging this is hammered deep out to
right field jose marmaleos going deep to
give the mariners a 2-1 lead in the
sixth inning his fourth of the season
and man he likes hitting here in anaheim
jose marmaleo's puts the mariners in
front it's two to one
two outs nobody on last to the sixth
anthony's strike three called trout just
drops his head
he strikes out for the third time facing
marco gonzalez this afternoon [ __ ] to
your one for three day this little flare
out the left field upton's coming on
strong he'll go into the dive and he'll
make the backhanded catch for the third
out real nice play by jaya justin up and
coming to the plate 2-1 ball game in the
seventh
[Applause]
they hit it deep but it's staying in the
ballpark marco gonzalez retires the side
in order he has sat down the last 18
angels hitters in a row he is dialed in
felix payne on the mound here's sega on
one a kyle drive into right center field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
over to cut it off in the gap is adele
so kyle seeger with a one out single
here in the top of the eighth inning one
on and two outs for the mariners here in
the top of the eighth inning that'll
bring up first baseman evan white
got him upstairs
and the ending is over so a pair of
strikeouts for
kenya in the end joe hey otani who's
pinch hitting for anthony bembo pull
shift is on as he breaks his bat loops
went out to shallow right that's going
to fall in for a base hit the barrel
ends up in the outfield grass the tying
run at first here's simmons he'll line
this one out to center field is it going
to hang up for lewis he plays it on a
hop two on with nobody out here in the
ninth inning some stress now on marco
gonzalez with trout there's the first
one the trout pulls on the third seeker
has it fires the second double play
shohei gets doubled up two outs
two on seattle bottom of the ninth two
on with two outs the one nothing pitch
the pujols
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna end it
right here complete game for mark go
gonzalez and the mariners win it two to
one